well this show is progressing fast
it's just like my kitten look at that
it's just a full-on cat
what's happening to you hey what's up
guys my name is achana welcome back to
another
hazel devlog and i've got some more
exciting features as always
to show you guys now this stuff is more
along the lines of the physx kind of 3d
physics stuff that we've been working on
specifically peter 1745 i should say
because the majority of this work really
ties into what he's been doing
so last time i showed you guys 3d
physics working in general i'll have the
devlog linked up there in case you
haven't seen it
and today i want to build off of that
and show you an actual 3d scene that we
can kind of walk around
in now i haven't had much time to author
content really
for hazel at the moment so this stuff is
very hastily kind of put together just
for demos really but we basically have a
demo now that shows
a kind of first person character
controller walking through a 3d world
which i think is really cool so the way
that this works is pretty simple
and it's really kind of extensible as
well there's essentially a capsule
collider component that you can add to
some kind of object or entity inside
hazel
and then you can hook that up with a
c-sharp script that basically will just
send out various impulses and
forces essentially when you like hit the
wasd keys and then we've also got a
camera entity that is
essentially being set to wherever the
mouse should be based on the player and
we don't have parenting and like child
entities yet so we can't just make the
camera
a child of the i guess player entity
just yet although we are working on that
so at the moment this demo really is
just showing a separate camera entity a
separate player entity a player entity
which has a capital collider and a c
sharp script which is like our fps
controller c sharp script
interacting with or and controlling
essentially a camera entity which
is your actual camera the cool thing
about all of this is
that all of the kind of interaction that
happens when we actually hit the play
button
is completely just c scripted i mean we
have obviously the physx kind of run
time as well and we're simulating those
physics
but every every kind of response to the
mouse and to
wasd keys the space bar to jump all of
that stuff
is completely programmed into c sharp so
it's really quick
quick to iterate over there's no need to
like recompile any c plus plus code and
it's not even integrated as part of a
component
it's just scripted in c sharp so that's
really cool because it feels like it's
actually
something that was made inside hazel so
i've got a couple of scenes to show you
and i can't wait to do that but first
this video is sponsored by skillshare
for those of you who have not heard of
skillshare skillshare skillshare's
amazing online learning community where
millions of creative and curious people
from all around the world can come
together to learn a new skill
in really short concise beautifully just
beautifully produced
bite-sized episodes of content i'm
really happy to continue working with
skillshare because
it honestly is one of my favorite
educational platforms online whether
you're interested in various kinds of
arts such as illustration photography
videography that kind of stuff
or productivity business management
marketing
i mean skillshare has you covered pretty
much anywhere it's honestly so easy to
just
type in something you want to learn
about into skillshare and then see a
bunch of classes pop up i mean i've been
doing this pretty often
earlier in the week i mentioned that
this year was the year of content and
specifically i've just embarked upon the
journey of making a game
that's quite a complicated process and
it involves learning
so many new skills that i just haven't
learned before
so being able to hop onto skillshare and
learn about things like
how to create awesome concept art or how
to get better at writing that kind of
stuff
i have really really enjoyed coming in
at just under 10
a month for an annual subscription
skillshare is an extremely affordable
way to actually further your knowledge
and they've been nice enough to offer
the first 1000 of you who clicked the
link in the description a free trial of
skillshare premium so that you can
explore your creativity
huge thank you again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video i think
they're going to be really useful to me
this year okay so first person
controllers
capsule colliders phys x let's take a
look at all of this
okay so what i've done here is put
together a fairly basic scene
as i mentioned unfortunately don't have
too much time to create actual
good-looking content for hazel just yet
although that is the plan for the year
so here we have a basic mesh this is
just a single mesh and then we also have
this kind of player entity that's a
capsule collider
as always i'll take you through what
this scene actually consists of because
that's
both a good way to show hazel's workflow
as well as actually show what goes into
making a scene like this and how
everything fits in together and as
always if there's something
if there's something with this that
feels a bit off to you or you think that
might potentially be a more intuitive or
easier way to do this please let me know
in the comments below i'm always looking
for feedback so as i mentioned there's
really only two real i guess entities in
this scene there's this kind of level
mesh that i put together in blender and
like
set up materials for and textured and
did all of that stuff and there's also
this player capital collider so the
level itself
is very simple it's a basic entity with
with a transform and a mesh component
which of course is this mesh
as well as a static rigid body and a
mesh collider on it so
physx will automatically generate this
kind of triangle mesh for us
from uh the actual geometry here so we
have a perfect mesh that we can collide
with
this mesh as you can see is fairly
simple i mean obviously there's some
extra vertices here because
as i mentioned did not they did not pay
attention to like the topology or
anything like that for this mesh
just made it in like uh in five minutes
but ultimately speaking it's a very
simple mesh
and that's really good for for use as a
collision mesh
there is an option to override the mesh
and actually pick a different mesh this
could be useful
for you know if you have a really
detailed mesh but you want the collision
mesh to be less detailed at the moment
you literally have to pick like a
different file but in the future this
will probably
they'll probably be an option to pick a
sub mesh from within
the actual fbx file or whatever mesh
asset file you're using
because it's pretty common to actually
put put both the collision mesh and then
the actual kind of
mesh you want to render uh into one file
into one asset okay so that's the main
level but then we also have the player
the player is
also also has a mesh component on it
with transform component of course
and then a script which we'll get to in
a minute it's got a dynamic rigid body
with some settings set up
and some constraints as well to freeze
the rotation and then there's also a
physics material and a mesh collider on
it as well
there actually shouldn't be a mesh i
thought there was a capsule collider on
there so
apparently i did end up putting a convex
mesh collider on this
instead of a capsule collider which is a
bit odd usually you would use a capsule
collider in this case but
it doesn't matter too much i'll show
this example in the other example i
prepared i've got a proper capsule
collider i didn't even realize that
anyway so this is like a basic setup for
kind of uh you know having this player
object but of course everything as i
mentioned is coming from
this fps player script which contains a
whole bunch of parameters that we've
exposed
into the c plus plus code and the result
is if i hit play you can see that
i can move my mouse around we can jump
into this kind of play mode
we can actually look at the the capsule
that is us
as well as look around the world and of
course the wasd keys and the space key
as well
uh will jump and so we can actually move
around this world which is pretty cool
so i can uh you know i've created this
little obstacle course that i can jump
on
um and everything looks pretty nice so
there you go that is a basic little fps
controller that we have here
um and the ability to work to walk
around a 3d world now of course because
this is generated from
the actual mesh you could make any mesh
you want here and just jump into it and
explore it like this
which is actually a really nice way of
of uh
you know i guess feeling scale of a
scene that you're working on because
being able to walk around
inside the actual scene rather than look
at it from like an editor-style camera
is extremely beneficial and we if we hit
escape we'll get our mouse pointer back
um this is hasn't been fully ironed out
yet
and then we can hit the stop button of
course and return to this so that's
pretty cool if i um
drag this up somewhere more interesting
maybe and spawn us into the world
from here that should be pretty cool
let's hit play and there you go we fall
down
and then we're here now okay so that's a
basic kind of fps controller inside
hazelnow which i think is pretty cool
now let's take a look at the other scene
now the other scene that peter
originally made was
this uh sponsor scene which makes sense
because we've been using the sponsor
model for a bunch of testing
why not use it to test the kind of fps
controller as well
so over here inside our player you can
you can see that we've actually got a
real capsule collider here
uh the i don't think the preview kind of
mesh renders correctly for the collider
which is what the green mesh is but
we'll ignore that
um we can set a capsule collider with a
radius and a height and whether or not
it's a trigger or an actual real kind of
physics entity
uh and then i mean i've got directional
light a skylight and a camera as well
and that's one thing i didn't mention in
the previous scene by the way the script
actually looks for an entity called
camera and controls the camera that way
so
the script is attached to player will
actually change the camera's translation
and orientation
to match that of what the player should
be looking at so that's how this is
actually hooked up
and then of course we do like all of the
physics stuff such as triggering the
forces
uh from within the c sharp script as
well so if i hit play on this one you
can see we have a
similar scene this camera actually is a
little bit
um narrow field of view but more or less
the same kind of scene i think there's a
bit of an offset apply here as well
and uh yeah we can actually walk around
sponsor which is pretty cool and even
jump down here and uh
and explore it from this way so this is
um
where we're at in terms of uh i guess
all the
fps controller and being able to
actually use nvidia physx
for um you know for uh more than just
simulating bouncy balls but now actually
creating like a world that we can
collide with and uh and go into which is
of course pretty cool
all right so i hope you guys enjoyed
this little look at all the new stuff
inside hazeldev
if you like this video please don't
forget to hit the like button below if
there's certain areas inside this video
that you want me to expand on and go
deeper into please let me know in the
comments below
don't forget you can also help support
hazel's development and everything that
you see me do here on youtube by going
to patreon.com the channel
you'll get access to this exact code so
that you can run it yourself as well as
a huge backlog of live streams and other
exclusive content to check out huge
thank you to all of you for your support
and huge thank you to peter1745 as well
for all of his amazing work
on all of this thank you guys for
watching don't forget to check the link
in the description below for your free
trial of skillshare premium and i will
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you